Speaker 1: But there is a problem.
There's a big problem. By the way,
facing the Republican Party. And that problem
happens to be that the largest voting bloc in
the United States. Millennials and Generation Z
voters absolutely despise the Republican Party.
New data has come out from the
2022 election. That tells us.
That's 77% of Generation Z voters said they
voted for a Democratic candidate for Congress
last year versus only 21% who said they voted
for a Republican. So we've got a 77 to 21%
split between Generation Z voters alone and of
course, millennials. Maybe not that extreme,
but still overwhelmingly vote for Democrats. Those
two blocks combined now make up the largest voting
bloc in the United States, outnumbering the
baby boomers, which happens to be the largest
voting bloc for the Republicans. Republicans also
have the added I don't want to call it tragedy,
but I guess it is a tragedy of the fact that they
let a lot of their followers and supporters die.
During the pandemic. They were
out there trashing vaccines.
They were out there telling people, you
don't have to wear a mask. That's oppression.
And they saw a lot of their voters, a lot of
their supporters, a lot of their core base die off
because of that. And I think, by the way,
that is a statistic. It's a grim statistic,
but that's something that most people completely
ignored during the 2022 midterms. I mean,
I talked about it a lot because study after study
after study showed us that the COVID death rates
in red areas of the country, red counties were
exponentially higher than in blue counties.
That may be one of the reasons why Republicans,
who a year ago were predicting a 70 seat pickup
in the House only have a couple seats in their
majority. I think that's something that needs to
be taken into consideration, especially since we
still have people dying in this country of COVID.
And those deaths are the overwhelmingly
unvaccinated part of the population.
So Republicans have a problem with their voting
bloc because they're still letting them die off.
And then they got a problem with the young voters
who want nothing to do with the Republican Party.
And the reason, of course,
is because young voters,
the millennials and the Generation Z voters
overwhelmingly support action on gun control.
They overwhelmingly support taking action on
the issue of climate change. They overwhelmingly
support LGBTQ issues. They support access
to abortion. They support all of the things
that Republicans have openly declared
war on here in the United States. And
what's funny is that the Republicans have
obviously, you know, acknowledged this.
But here is what Ronna McDaniel, the chair of
the Republican National Committee, had to say.
When we do when we do that and we
talk about economic opportunity,
the things our party stands for, we'll win those
voters over. We just have to compete for them.
See, here's the problem with your plan, Rana.
First of all, it's completely wrong anyway.
Second of all, you don't have a plan to pitch
to these voters. But you don't have a plan to
pitch to any voters right now. The only plans
we're hearing about from the Republican Party
are let's raise the retirement age for the young
people. Let's make them just keep working and
working and working and working. Nikki Haley
has that plan. She's she said that in a speech
recently. Republicans in Congress suggested
it like, let's just raise the retirement age.
You think that generation that has no
nothing but hardship and wars based on
lies and pandemics throughout their whole
lives, You think they want to hear that?
But beyond that, what is your plan? What is your
economic plan? Republicans. Can anyone watching
this tell me what a Republican economic plan is?
And tell me who is pushing it and what it would
do for the country. Anyone? The answer is no,
you can't because such a thing doesn't exist.
I am 40 years old. Throughout my lifetime,
Republicans. Have had one plan other than outside
of culture war stuff. I'm talking about one
actual legislative plan My entire life, that one
plan has been to cut taxes. It's been trickle down
economics my entire life. Every time Republicans
get power, the first thing they want to do is
cut taxes. We've already seen the Republican
majority in the House of Representatives propose
cutting taxes again, extending the Trump tax cuts.
It doesn't work and this generation knows it.
This generation isn't afraid to call it out.
They're not buying into those lies of Reaganomics.
And they're angry. And as long as Republicans
continue to push that, they will never attract
these younger generations. We have to take a quick
break. I'm Ferron Cousins again. You can subscribe
to my YouTube channels at YouTube.com, slash the
Ring of Fire and YouTube.com slash fair and
balanced. And I'm on Twitter, Instagram,
TikTok, and Facebook at fair and Balanced. We'll
be right back with more on the David Pakman show.